let's just note down okay for roofs for
rooms six people right is that right
six people yep and maximum of four nine
okay that's it hundred eternal okay now
have you got that
Wow look at all those incredible details
there how are you they do this now my
suggestion is you try and see there's a
parallel between the way you approach
this question and the way you can
approach a question like that it's only
mathematicians you can see hostel rooms
hotel rooms and pack their cards as like
oh these are basically the same right
there are two qualities two attributes
that I need to choose from each time
within this situation okay
and I've written them they're on the
board right you got to choose a person
and then you've got to choose a room for
that person and that's it okay % % room
person group so I'm gonna go through
this as logical as a way I can now first
honest like let's just think about this
let's just think about this first okay
don't worry about the restriction
restrictions are very confusing
sometimes just think about the problem
first before the restrictions come in
and then add them okay if I've got six
people and four groups okay
how many ways are there just to put them
into rooms okay well first I'm gonna
pick a person then I'm gonna put a room
a pic of room to for them to go into
okay so I'm going to treat each person
individually this will seem a bit weird
I'm gonna say um I'm going to say
without restriction first it may seem a
bit redundant to do what I'm about to do
but first step this pick a person bit
but you'll see why it's so important
when we get to their restrictions okay
if there are no restrictions then I'm
going to pick one person or a designated
right now there's only one way to pick
one person out of a group of one we're
gonna look at that person in particular
because I'm telling pop right so I'm
gonna pick them and then I'm gonna pick
a room for them to go into okay there
are four rooms to choose from and that
one person can only go in one room
right so I've picked a person a single
individual and then I picked a room for
them to go into okay now remember there
are no restrictions right so I have to
do this
another five times yes so in other words
in total I do this six times great
we know that's 1 for C 1 is 4 for an
hour 6 is all right yeah I know I know
and this is without restrictions right
and by the way yes this is one of them
like when you look at a multiple choice
and you're like oh I got a number
numbers on the multiple choice right we
call this in the business we call this a
distractor right it's like oh I did
something valid but I haven't gone all
the way there yeah I didn't even know
which matter it is I can tell you what I
know it's all right now yeah yeah that's
right
ok I'm now gonna deal with the
restrictions now is a maximum of 4 okay
I know this might seem a bit like that
why do this this way but right the
beginning of probability if you remember
I mention if there's like a reasonably
small step just list them just list them
now that's not what I'm talking about
that's not list of okay but what I say
there's a maximum fall of her room all
that means is you can't have six and you
can't have five I can do that that's
totally manageable okay let's do them
one at a time doing six at a time six in
one room okay this is actually easy to
work out think about my pattern
can we come out my path I've got to pick
people and then I've got a pic of room
for them to go into okay I need to pick
all six people if you've got six people
to choose from and you've got to choose
all of them then that's six C 6 isn't it
that makes sense that's how many ways I
can pick the group of six cuz that's all
of them so you're one way then I've got
to pick a room for them to go into
that's 41
okay do I have to do this more times
no I've dealt with all the people this
is for okay so there are four ways to
have six in one room that's something
which I'm gonna have to eliminate out of
a number of ways okay now here's where
the worst word is how many ways are
there to get five in one now we've done
all the setup I hope this will make
sense for you I've gotta pick people
first pick the people okay there are a
few different ways to pick the people 6c
five out of the six I'm gonna pick five
okay now I've got to put them in a room
right how many rooms are there too
strong
have I dealt with all the people yet I
am NOT there's another person to deal
with so I'll pick them there's only one
way to take them now stop for a second I
only want five in a room what rooms
already taken with the group right so
then I have three see one rooms for this
last poor loner who maybe stores really
loud to go into okay there are three
options
that's number of ways to put five people
in one room and the other guy right
and then obviously there are vacant
rooms how many ways is that so I've
worked out
I've worked out the compliment now
haven't I but this is without
restriction I don't what this one and I
don't want that one so therefore the
total number of ways is 4096 take away
take away seventy-two looks like 4000
okay now this is well and truly an
extension one question it is a harder
extension one question but look at all
the tools we used and see yeah it's fine
Taoists working out how many people are
gone
combining them in an interesting
conditions and then taking the
difference okay but it is hard because
it's like I don't even wait about the
game with this kind of question well now
that you've seen you can use this this
and that this and that you can use it
for cards you can use it for hotel rooms
you can use it for me people driving in
cars and carpooling so on the same
okay that's what mathematics what you
see